condolences go to Lord Britain's
families obviously a very sad day for
for his family there's no doubt about
that what do you think are the questions
which he should have answered had he
been able to before he died as far as
the child abuse allegations are
concerned well there are a number of
questions that Lord Britain clearly
needed to answer first and foremost they
needed to tell tell the inquiry that
still not got underwear properly what he
knew with regard to the abuse
allegations that were circulated in the
1980s we do know that Leon Brittan met
with Jeffrey Dickens the Conservative MP
who created a dossier and campaigned on
child abuse issues amet within received
that dossier what was in that dossier
what the Jeffrey Dickens have to say to
him the dossier allegedly makes a number
of points about abusers who were
circulating in and around London at that
time and what we now know is that we'll
never get to the bottom of that because
one of the key witnesses for the
overarching inquiry into child sexual
abuse is passed away and that sad not
just for Lord Britain's family but also
sad for the survivors of child sex abuse
because they would have hoped to learn
more from what Lord Britain would have
had to tell them it's an enquiry as far
as his handling of the allegations that
were passed to him when he was home
secretary are you satisfied as the
walnuts inquiry appeared to be that he
bathed entirely properly I'm not
convinced by that I think what Leon
Brittan had to say whilst it was alive
with regard to the dossier and what went
on during the 1980s was Ollie inadequate
it was very limited what he had to say
about it the allegations around this
type of abuse have been circulating for
a number of years and it could have
taken the opportunity to share his
knowledge in some detail in terms of
what had gone on during the 1980s when
he was the Home Secretary buddy but he
never did that with regard to the one
lyst review which was commissioned by
the Home Secretary back in July what
would Nolan's is that was wholly in
adequate one less whitewashes it's
become more commonly known because not
all the documents were found indeed one
crop top earlier this week that showed
that Margaret Thatcher or suggested that
Margaret Thatcher was aware of some of
the abuse that was going on in a report
that was passed to her so the the one
this review failed to establish that so
there's so many questions to be answered
and the Home Secretary has been dragging
her feet in terms of his establishing
this enquiry and people are left
wondering why is taking so long and
indeed read a debate on the government's
failure to progress the inquiry just
this morning in Parliament and the Home
Secretary was dithering and not being
clear in terms of what successes inquiry
would ever when it would actually be
established and we left wondering if she
didn't know this morning that that there
needed to be some urgency around this
inquiry she certainly knows it this
afternoon because we have seen the death
of a key witness who would have appeared
before that enquiring finally how
significant is this hitherto
undiscovered file that Sky News has been
reporting on that now we understand has
been passed to the police investigators
well we know that the Cabinet Office
about this file for a good number of
days I've been aware of this fouls
existence for a number of weeks so we're
aware of the documents and why they
can't establish whether it's a new
document or what's in it i think is on
alphaland leads towards wondering what
the Cabinet Office and indeed the Home
Office are doing about these issues what
they should now do is perhaps we do you
know redact some of the documents if it
is sensitive but publish the documents
so that we can see for ourselves exactly
what it contains and whether it's of any
importance Simon tantric MP thank you
very much d for joining us